ah
I appreciate that so much
you
you must be out of towners is that what
it is if you're a madam stay please help
yourself to some fire you know we got
plenty you go to Vermont you get maple
syrup you come here take home a little
fire
now we're always weather conscious here
in California they said today this is
the big news out here El Nino is coming
and they say it might end our four-year
drought of course corsa jaded
Californians went a great rain
I'm
we are begging El Nino to hit us that is
what it has come to we are praying for
one weather disaster to save us from the
other weather disaster and we need it I
mean as if we don't have enough problems
you know we get some of our water that
little that's left from the Colorado
River and the EPA did you see this was
weak spilled DPA who's supposed to
parentis spilled three million gallons
of acid mine sludge into the river
turned the river yellow and toxic it's a
huge screw-up but Donald Trump said it
gave him a great idea how to keep
Mexicans from crossing the Rio Grande
I mean when are we going to start
cherishing this planet a little bit did
you see the explosions in China
yesterday two massive explosions of the
giant hazardous chemical warehouse and
it's it's of course very sad because
those hazardous chemicals were destined
to come here and make your kids toys
shinier and your Doritos taste great so
that's but they said the explosion
happened at night was so big it made the
night sky look like day and I tell you
in China between the explosions making
the night look like day and the
pollution making the day look like night
so wonder if these people get to sleep
at all but how about how about some good
foreign news today we raised the
American flag in Cuba for the first time
for like 60 years yes after our fabulous
55 year diplomatic strategy of we're not
talking to you John Kerry went there and
opened an American Embassy in Cuba
because he said look for too long Cuban
people have been deprived of first of
all American tourists hey Cubans
fat white people trying to dance to
salsa music you're gonna love us let me
play it but you know other than Marco
Rubio when a few old Cubans in Miami
nobody gives a [ __ ]
worrying about Castro with this ports
like boring about Bobby Jindal 's
presidential campaign yes it's down
there somewhere but doesn't matter well
that brings me to the presidential
campaign and I'm certainly glad
something good because today what's the
big I owe a State Fair
all the candidates Iowa yeah you're glad
you're here with the fire no I love Iowa
but all the candidates were there this
is true Donald Trump flew in on his
private helicopter and wanted offered to
give free helicopter rides to the kids
that's true now I mean as another how do
you compete with that seriously
chris Christie tried he offered to be
the bouncy house I mean yeah
Trump said today he had a plan to defeat
Isis
I would laugh except his plan to defeat
Fox News worked it's interesting every
week Donald Trump says something crazy
insane outlandish and everybody goes of
that that's it that's his downfall and
then he's fine
he's like Godzilla everything they throw
at the monster makes him stronger people
thought last week that after the debate
performance Trump would go away you're
so silly you are watching the debate
with your brain to understand the
Republican mindset you have to watch it
with your balls when Donald Trump says I
will make China behave the brain goes
wet and the balls go damn straight and
it's about time somebody said that about
got it good you got to give Trump credit
for this no teleprompter he just pulls
it out of his whatever oh you saw that
yes this is the latest scandal period
gate he he was mad at megyn kelly for
asking him rough questions at the debate
and he implied that she was being mean
to him because she just she was
menstruating that was I mean he said she
had blood coming out of her eyes she had
blood coming out of her whatever what
could he have meant stigmata is that
what he was talking about yes she's like
our Lord and Savior she is and it's so
funny you know Fox who was trying to
destroy Donald Trump they said after
they had very important that we defend
megyn kelly take a principled stand
protect our beloved employee then they
looked at the ratings from the debate
with Donald Trump and they were like
maybe Megan was on the rag you know I
wish and Trump said trying to recover
Trump said he is open to having a female
vice president I mean - those few days
when they're a little crazy
you